asteroid on a collision course with
their extinction event 80% of the
Earth's population dead God turned his
back on humanity long ago it wasn't a
war was it global warming it was a
[ __ ] asteroid
I was born in this [ __ ] parents
murdered an orphan of this wasteland an
army of mutants killed everyone I ever
loved
all that's left is hate
fear and the need for survival
see part of growing up was watching
everything get taken from I stood by did
nothing and now I'm the last Ranger of
this wasteland and there's only one
thing left to do
hello III and welcome to the world of
Rage too
in a moment we'll dive headfirst into
the Eaton spaceport mission where Walker
our main protagonist is out to find a
rare artifact that will aid him in his
quest to take down the authority
[Music]
poaching the Eden Space Center yes I
forgot to say it might be overrun by
bandits the gone is gone to be precise
you must likely slay them first before
falling down the EcoPOD from orbit and
securing the gun taken a note right in
there in
doctor made the space center keep your
wits about you Walker the goons what may
look whimsical laughable even but
believe me behind their playful
appearance
it sings rockets but good digging of
food it mounts on the wall its motion
sensor activated if the ruckus the
crusher talking at a key and it can be
yours file to 5h
in case your way into the EcoPOD Mission
Control of the third floor
Savannah are no longer present threat
has been nullified mr. president welcome
excellent
now look for the central computer you
will initiate a recall procedure for eco
15 still in orbit we call sequence
approved beginning echo my regards
the EcoPOD made no and so does the
authority sorry
get the untainted nano tights and get
out also for you there is an extra bone
something that will make you a veritable
so far here of elevator still running so
far
looks like Ranger Walker's gonna get a
bit of a boost today
[Music]
Oh